okay hi Dave Johnson what are you
interested in I actually have small cats
do you want a kiss score masseuses you
see you get the chills between me or
hops over here who do you like I got I
got pretty lips lips I've got really
nice and firm hands trust me they're
pretty fur
be hello can you hear me
this is lot of repeating for duty
hello hello you have a very masculine
voice thank you
are you sure you're what female yes yes
do you already
it's got boom I don't know oh well I
haven't changed my night I'm not I'm not
I'm not pay they do you mistaken me with
someone else
thank you so good a guy can't understand
ocker why am i flying I'm a [ __ ] and my
name is the Rodriguez I can store in my
pocket you can put me in your pocket
shoulda picked another name I think I
think I escaped them okay you did not
I [ __ ] now I'm trapped I will personally
stalk you alright no one takes another
step or I'll do it I'll jump swear to
God
no if I don't not know this back up back
up thank you uh just yeah don't kill
herself also what you say that Phillip
is the best youtuber ever oh I'll do it
PD pi is a mediocre beating ruin I
didn't die that was pretend to climatic
okay everyone ready now No
call out your lover's name when you jump
all right one two three no lettuce yeah
wait you skank how dare you only you
jumped it to like hey I gave a cellphone
new floor oh you did
you're welcome on it cool you're a comic
you good you have now a new hat you are
very welcome
that will be $500 much appreciated
what $500 place no no no might take the
touch with you the hell is going on
this is big throw that thing up the roof
let it go god damn it
uh yeah what whoa whoa on the end of
there we down yep it's gonna let on that
couch I got a bunch of no pants talkin
to me
the are welcome cry I built myself it's
anyone else wanna [ __ ] with my serves
anyone hey thanks Oh
stand on my stairs I dare you let's go
back he's messing with our table man
what that's our table okay thank you
this with a table got problem problem
with tongues are your table hater inside
that no one messing with hops say you're
sorry say you're sorry nothing against
you
that's fine spot a problem drop weird
you go for now go lol in peace alright
we're starting a shop over here so Jesus
guys give us some space don't punch
table [ __ ]
mother do you know how hard he worked on
that table do you know how hard there
was no respect for other people
Hobson is okay so we're giving out free
kisses here they're not free free okay
five five dollars for a kiss picking out
three kisses and then say that they are
five dollars in kisses yes we can no
question our business okay
oh my god what is that over there my god
what have you created created what is
that hey reg antic Pig was a robot anus
from space my first kiss to a mob it's
totally a big did you do it yeah
I feel dirty our physics physics put the
barrels in it yes put the barrels all
right yeah the barrels are bad and must
be shot out of a cannon this guy knows
what he's talking about at least don't
you get something inside All Right see
you want a massage from a guy who got a
motorbike okay mom as I might imagine
something smaller
go for it ascension and sadness I was
gonna [ __ ] out of this man thank you
what it is we know what is happening MA
well hope that was a good bacillus okay
now we just need a sign
kissing company alright here's our sign
I got it Oh awesome
yep it is pretty good perfect can I be
your dog and what but you have to bark
constantly only you can go to the
bathroom is really slippery what what
did you there open is beautiful
Oh curved I can't wait
I head late haha that's how you hear
that was me
can I have a break if you know what I
mean I have no idea do you mean them dog
and you should poop stop bombing the
[ __ ] couch why are you punching at
the mayor
so daughter